foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay it's time to play the music it's
time to dress up right
it's time to meet Bernardin oh don't we
meet Bernardin it's time to meet Bernard
and on the fat man show tonight oh well
done well done
you remember the one episode of The
Muppet Show when um like you know it
wasn't one episode but periodically they
would do an opening
where the old guy sang I don't think
they sang in every episode but like
there was a version where they were like
why do we always come here I guess we'll
never know
when they go to the bridge when like the
show's a little bit shorter like listen
wait another 30 seconds so walk off and
Statler get in there one of the old guys
um did you ever say that Saturday Live
sketch I think it was um
um uh the the show that was like the
second to last of last season where um
God who's the host
um
[ __ ] I don't know but it was him
and uh I'm all Stony boy I'm losing
details
um who's been on the show for like 15
years
played Fat Albert
Keenan and Kell
yes
he he was one like they were security at
The Muppet Show and so they had two
puppet versions of Statler and Waldorf
and they were making their comments but
then he would come out and be like
welcome to fat man beyond man I'm uh
Kevin Smith I am Mark minhart hey
welcome to the first fat man beyond
of the new year for heaven's sakes Miss
2023
and me and Mark are still here and we're
doing it we are can't get rid of us
he's in the bat cave
I'm in the I'm in the movie theater I'm
upstairs
broadcasting live from smodcast Castle
Cinemas
um next week I start a new job apropos
nothing oh what is this Amazon Amazon
has a radio a live radio program called
amp you could download it it's an app
and um Monday Wednesday and Friday
morning I'm doing a show called uh Movie
music in the morning
where I play you know songs from movies
and then Chit Chat and blah blah blah
that sounds like fun yeah right like at
the end of the day and so you remember
how Z100 was like
um from the top of the Empire State
Building where they really didn't
broadcast from they were just referring
to the broadcast antenna
like every radio station in New York
broadcasts from the top of the Empire or
you know the Empire State Building
because that's where the antenna was but
they used that as their hook on Z100
even though they were nowhere in New
York they were in New Jersey so their
bumpers were like from the top of the
Empire State Building
late in [ __ ] marketing Swindle
um I'm not gonna my mine's gonna be like
from the top of smart Castle Cinemas
because I'm really literally on the
[ __ ] top floor of spot Castle Cinemas
so there's truth in my advertising
that's why I'm getting it
um go download amp kids listen to me
next week
yeah just next week or is this like
going for a long time you can go forever
until they get tired of me I think hey
it's bamf man one of my favorite trivia
rounds that I've ever done was an audio
round where I played like 30 seconds of
a song like uh uh Shoot to Thrill and
you had to tell me what Marvel movie it
was from oh so it's good that could be a
really fun theme for one of your shows
right now let's play that now well I
don't think we can actually play music
we still want to be on the air yeah
YouTube will kick us up you can't even
show trailers from my own movies without
getting [ __ ] thrown off YouTube and
[ __ ] but what a fun game that would be
that's cool uh so yeah there's that part
is that part of the bar trivia yeah it's
part of the bar trivia
when you do bar trivia how's that go
like how do I do it
yeah it's crowded it's pretty crowded uh
I love other answering questions don't
they
it's uh well it's the only place we had
a write-up in the LA Times around
Thanksgiving and it's like the only
football for trivia yeah for Skillman
villainy trivia because it's the
it's the only one that's like holy pop
culture nerd themed so oh good for you
man get some ink so yeah it was cool and
we've been busy I mean we were busy
before that we're busier now uh because
people are like oh hey I I want to go
answer questions about Buffy the Vampire
Slayer
I don't not about Buffy but I would love
to answer the question I would love
[ __ ] trivia man come out here and do
it at the movie theater bro I'll do it
I'll come out
um the uh I too have been
I I too am in the asses and seats
business just like you my friend
um with smodcast Castle Cinemas and I
have been having a blast we uh announced
a mallrat screening last week sold out
so fast Jason uh Lee and Jeremy London
is going to be there
um then we put up clerks open all night
was the thing I've been talking about
forever I'm like when I buy that movie
theater we're gonna [ __ ] do a a
marathon of Clerks movies like from 11
30 at night till six in the morning and
we put up on sale I I honestly thought
like 50 to 100 people Max would buy
tickets sold it out
so like it's we're having a good time
here tonight after we're done 10 o'clock
I got Friday the 13th on Friday the 13th
so I'm gonna go down intro the screening
and [ __ ] and then tomorrow night right
here at smart Castle Cinemas
um we've got the merry Marvel movie
Society we're watching Iron Man bro last
week we watched last week we watched uh
we had Fat Man on Batman film club we
had 181 people come watch [ __ ] Tim
Burton's Batman
I love that [ __ ] man that makes me so
[ __ ] happy oh oh
I like being a like movie theater that
plays current movies but I like our
ability to
show older stuff as well
um yeah it's been good times man Mark's
coming out I am confirmed that he's
coming out for the Ides of Mark kids I
did I I absolutely told Kev that I'm
booking hotels I'm looking at flights
I'm I'm planning that uh those four days
in March
or I'm going to come and descend upon
the smog Castle Cinemas that's right
we're gonna watch um movies
with Mark and then we end the Ides of
Mark with a live fat man beyond right
there at smog Castle Cinemas kids oh
it's good yeah and I gotta I gotta talk
to the guys at the stash because I
remember they wanted to do a signing
while they do is Adora back in print a
door is back in print so Adora the
recent winner of the Dwayne McDuffie
diversity and Comics award
where uh well it was it was a virtual
ceremony
um but uh young Phil Lamar was the emcee
it said ceremony I Love Phil Lamar
Phil's the best
um and so he got to he got to present
and read and he read whatever whatever I
had videotaped an award speech as did
the artist Ariella cristentina and uh
and this one it was it was a it was a
lovely way to cap a year of talking
about Adora a year of promoting Adora
you're selling Adora but it was it was a
nice little bookend
for that process now take it from a man
who has never stopped selling clerks I
don't know if you know or not but we
have three a third one recently Mark
um you're not done with the Dora you get
to [ __ ] string that Victory out if
you're you're smart for 30 years
you've got an A eon in high school and
your mom still has it on the fridge when
you're married
I keep on turning in for different
classes
uh sir this is an economics class and
that's a social studies paper from 11th
grade
doesn't matter
um
yeah man it's gonna be good times odds
of Mark man great scene can come out
this month I think he's gonna JCPenney
coming out for uh for uh rasherman I'm
gonna come out uh maybe for the end I'll
make it I've got it I met Sundance until
the 24th so then I gotta figure out how
I can get out there after that listen to
Batman
he's like me and Bobby that's Robert
Redford we're gonna be [ __ ] rocking
Sunday not that exciting I do have uh I
have a clerks and Dogma story for you
though
I was with
um now I sound like a douchebag but I
was with Freddie Prince Jr yesterday
yeah
and uh he was just in clerks three with
this man because so I I said to him at
the end I was like uh God when you pop
up in clerks three I don't I like die
every time it's so funny and he's like
oh my God I I don't watch stuff I'm in
he's like I love Kevin's movies but I'll
never watch clerks 3 because I'm in it
what take did he use what do I do so I'm
describing to him and I was like and
then this person shows up and then this
person and they're all playing roles
like Ben Affleck is playing some John
from Boston I was like but then you show
up and you just go Freddie Prince Junior
auditioning for the role of
it's so funny he's slated he uh for
those who don't know the clerks three
um when we shot
fpj's Cameo and [ __ ] uh you know or Mr
Michelle Geller if you will
um he was uh like he's slated when an
actor auditions they say their name
slating is like so if I was auditioning
if this was like a self tape or whatever
the phone I'd be like Kevin Smith you
know and then be like
listen man and go into my performance
and [ __ ] so he gave us a slate at the
top of his performance and I cut it into
the movie and I think he did it on
purpose like I don't think he was truly
slating to be like hey I'm afraid he was
just having a good time with it but I I
used it in the movie it's funny uh so it
was funny I was like oh my God he's
never seen it and then he told me a
story which I don't know if you even
know but he was dying to be in Dogma
and when you were casting Dogma or
auditioning or about to start shooting
I guess he had to be on a press tour for
She's All That in Japan and he called
Miramax and he was like this is a
mirrormax movie that's a mirror Max
movie wouldn't you rather I like get a
my face in Dogma then go to this thing
in Japan and they were like get on the
plane
so he's been he was hoping to be in
Dogma back in the day so doing clerks
three was like uh closing a 20-year Loop
for him
that's pretty dope man
yeah he's a good [ __ ] kid way into
wrestling
yeah yep I'm not saying that like it's a
character flaw but I mean you I would
never
he's just one of those people that you
would never be like this this was a guy
that like everybody wanted to [ __ ]
and he was and he's like way into
wrestling so much so I think he wanted
to write for for uh WWE at one point
didn't he yeah he's also
he's like a big uh martial arts guy so
he he's like a black belt and Judo or
something like that as well me really
yeah so I think it probably ties into
his martial arts background but me while
he was like you know [ __ ] like that
this dude was like in everything for a
stretch and then he kind of like I
walked away
um but never really truly walked away
because he had those Star Wars shows
over and over right and here's the
craziest thing is he's like the best
looking guy in every movie he's like the
hairy styles of like 1997 to like 2007
right and
uh
I'm helping him you're not [ __ ]
thirsty me and Banff man are friends
apparently God I mean he's a catch he's
a summer catch
thank you
thank you here's the crazy thing and
this is what you start to find out now
is that he's like a giant nerd he like
loves Dungeons and Dragons or stuff and
I'm all I can think of is like I'm he's
a few years older than me I was like man
if like you would just come out as like
a Dungeons and Dragons kid in 1998 and
like Vin Diesel had just come out as a
Dungeons and Dragons kid and Tom Morello
of Rage Against the Machine of all these
people are just uh quit hiding their
nerdum I think it would have been a lot
easier for me
yeah but now everybody is like oh I've
Loved this stuff since I was 12.
but it wasn't I don't think he would
have [ __ ] you anyway though
there is uh yeah I you know I I
benefited from leaning into [ __ ] early
on
you know once people start putting
microphones in my face like I never
shied away from talking about
the things that like you know [ __ ]
Juiced it for me and like made me
passionate
it just so happened that the things that
I was like way into
like timed out well in the culture that
like
suddenly other it became more these
things became marketable like [ __ ]
they you know became popular or whatever
pop culture became the dominant culture
and and uh
you know comic book culture in pop
culture like especially has taken the
Forefront and by being the guy early on
who was like oh I love this [ __ ]
like it it's
it's paid off you know what I'm saying
the lesson here is like kids don't hide
your light under a bushel if you like
something if I can tell people like
don't you know this world is so
concerned with telling everybody what it
doesn't like
you know you [ __ ] open Twitter or if
I can turn on
and TV and there's always somebody
telling you what's [ __ ] wrong and
[ __ ] like that what they don't like I I
you know be the other person the person
that tells people what the [ __ ] you like
because it can pan out not only is it
just better to be positive than negative
but like I would I didn't say this [ __ ]
hoping one day the culture would shift
in my favor and whatnot but like it did
and and
and I I was and it worked out for me
because I you know it was authentic
talking about [ __ ] that I that I loved
so you know never hide it unless you're
like unless you're a kid out there is
like I love Hitler don't [ __ ] tell
people or maybe tell somebody stop and
they'll get you out of that sort of
thing but yeah it's
I'm glad that I leaned into like
talking about comics and [ __ ] like that
you know like Mall Rats happened and
tanked well rats came out was a huge
flop man caused us five million to make
made two million dollars by any map
that's [ __ ] not good but it
established me as like oh he's that guy
he's that [ __ ] grown-ass idiot that
likes comics and then years later they
were like hey grown ass idiot that likes
Comics what do you have to say about
this [ __ ]
art that's why how me and Mark know each
other absolutely there wouldn't be a
podcast if you weren't the guy because I
was I was writing a story for
Entertainment Weekly and they're like
well you wanna I wanted to rate comic
book costumes
like get somebody to grade them and
they're like who am I gonna get and
somebody says well you should probably
get Kevin Smith because he's that guy so
like I called your publicist and he said
well all right sure because I'll bring
it to Kevin Kim's like yeah this sounds
like fun
that was our first conversation it was
like we got too much coffee Man's
costume beginning of a beautiful
friendship indeed because you you refuse
to to hide your freak flag under a
bushel that's true man just it's the
Phrase That Pays
is you know what I like
as opposed to you know it sucks you know
what I hate
like there's so much of that going on
that brand is so [ __ ] tired bro so
tired nobody wants to hear what you hate
anymore tell them what you love man
that'll go a lot further and [ __ ] spread
the good news and it's out there
um what it how many awards have you won
now for Adora was that nice um
no I mean nominated for for the Eisner
didn't pull off the Eisner
um
I think we were nominated for a harvey I
think
um and then we won the the the McDuffie
which means you know like I the eyes you
know would have been great I'm not going
to say there wouldn't have been great
but um but Dwayne McDuffie was a hero of
mine like in in the real world Cory
McDuffie if you don't know who Dwayne
McDuffie is Dwayne McDuffie was a comic
book writer for both Marvel and DC you
know wrote Justice League for a while
wrote like Fantastic Four for a while uh
moved over to animation wrote on
um Justice League it just like animated
like he he was this sort of Jack of all
trades
um who was a giant black dude at a time
in which you know the comics wasn't
overwhelmingly welcoming to Jack black
dudes
um but his talent was undeniable and so
he just kept on working and kept on
doing great great stuff and so he passed
I want to say at this point now it's
about 10 maybe 15 years ago
um
but I got to meet him once
um at a at a Warner Brothers animation
party at Comic-Con
um I think the year before he passed and
I got to tell him how much I loved his
damage control which was a book he did
for Marvel
um which is one of my favorite comic
books ever it was the the insurance
company that rebuilt New York after it
would always get destroyed well Galactus
is here they destroyed Central Park and
would come damage control and they would
fix it and they would send a bill to
somebody and they would as long as you
had your insurance policy kept up then
you got to have the protection of damage
control they would eventually bring
damage between the MCU a little bit
because they became the organization
that was policing the chachari artifacts
after the Avengers like they're the guys
who come and shut down
um the vulture in Spider-Man
um homecoming
um the department of damage control but
I got to tell him how much I loved it
and how much I ripped him off for a book
that I did called monster attack Network
and he said that's exactly what's
supposed to happen you read the things
that you love you find a way to make it
and incorporate it into the person that
you are and when you get to make
something you know there's going to be a
part of everything you've ever read in
everything you ever write it's again
that's that's the way it's supposed to
go so don't feel don't feel sheepish
don't feel bad you did your job I did my
job now somebody will read something you
wrote and some of you will be in there
and then some of me will be in that too
but I was like that is the most saves
thing I've ever heard from a dude who I
just told that I plagiarized
he skipped that part all together
like advice as opposed to being like
well number one don't steal number two
don't tell me you stole
[Laughter]
but he was he was a lovely guy and so
this this award does mean quite a bit to
me um with his name on it and to come
from Phil Lamar
um the king the king of all nerds the
king of all blurs
um also meant quite a bit
um let me tell you something you deserve
it that and so much more thank you
congratulations very very cool
very very cool
um all right what do we got man do we
have a sponsor yes we do have a sponsor
indeed kids before things get all sorts
of geeky
um we gotta pay our bills here man and
uh we got a sponsored
Manny Potts in this Muffler
um Native folks the good Folks at Native
um Native
if you want to follow along go to uh
nativedeo.com
um and and
check out their page as we talk about
them as we fellate native for you
um while you're doing that man uh if
you're gonna buy something you could
either enter nativedeo.com famine or use
the promo code Fatman at checkout man
that's nativedeo.com
Fatman or use the promo code Fatman at
checkout for 20 off your first daughter
man when it comes to personal hygiene
who has the time to read that long list
of ingredients in the back of the bottle
not me some ingredients I can't even
pronounce kids so if you're like me and
you care what goes on your body
candle wax on your nipples uh then it's
just chains whips
uh time to try native God damn it's good
Folks at Native they make a fine product
you know what their products so good I
don't even have to sell it so we're
gonna stop talking about it there you go
no I don't think that's how this
actually works I believe we have to talk
about the product and let me tell you
something I was just in a Target
saw a whole end cap all about Native man
uh don't buy from Target buy it from us
yeah get it from Us online for heaven's
sakes but I've seen it in the real world
if it's that Target it's real Mark
Target's as real as America gets maybe
Walmart maybe Walmart's a little more
real but
they it's out there natives out there
and somebody just this week was just
like I said something about Native in
there because I was talking about ads
and they were like oh my God I actually
use that stuff and I was like well a lot
of people do like don't say it like that
but they were surprised that I was doing
a podcast ad for something that they
would actually cost and I was like
that's right because native is amazing
man tell them what native's all about
Mark native every native product is
thoughtfully formulated to keep you
feeling and smelling fresh all day long
you know native for their aluminum-free
deodorant native keeps their ingredients
list bare naked with ingredients you can
understand like coconut oil and Shea
butter and baking soda the deodorant
checks a lot of boxes 72-hour order
protection naturally derived derived
ingredients and a smooth residue-free
application native also offers a variety
of scents with new and limited sense
being released all the time like warm
cider and cinnamon cashmere and rain ah
toasted marshmallow and vanilla Wildwood
and cardamom what when you use native
you will smell amazing all day long
thanks to their long-lasting scents and
if you want to smell woodsy and spicy or
clean and fresh they have a scent option
for everyone
so Now's the Time to make the switch
from an antiperspirant to Native when
you visit their site you can discover
all their fresh scents and maybe even
try one out one of their body washes
while you're at it strike that reverse
it try out one of their body washes
while you're at it so smelling smell and
feel fresh all day long with Native get
20 off your first odor by going to
nativedeo.com Fatman or use promo code
fat minute checkout that's nativedeo.com
Fatman or use promo code Fatman at
checkout for 20 off your first order
we love native we thank the good Folks
at Native for sponsoring this here
podcast
man beyond for as long as they have man
it's fine product kids when I want to
negate my stank
native
um
somebody just asked me a question and
said
that I had an answer for where is it
hero For Hire 007 says hello from
Manchester Manchester England England
the UK across the Atlantic City and I'm
a genius genius I believe in God and I
believe that God believes in Todd that's
me
um max Flay said Hey Kevin when's the
next Babylon well it's funny you should
ask I happen to know this next Hollywood
Babylon is going to be at Flappers
comedy club on February 25th I know this
because it's the five-year anniversary
of me not dying from a heart attack it's
the heart attack adversary show kids uh
so if you're in California if you're in
the Los Angeles area particularly in the
Burbank area because that's what can't
do that anymore people think that's
racist yeah I'm not sure exactly where
yeah maybe maybe just keep it like that
like I'm crushing your head I'm crushing
your head
what you can't say Okay anymore so they
took that
take everything nice
you know I thought we'd [ __ ] this fight
already but
uh wait what was I talking about oh uh
Hollywood Babylon Flappers comedy club
February 25th me celebrating being alive
five years after uh the my heart got
cute with me and had different ideas and
I said [ __ ] you and I razzled it back
down I razzled it like a polar bear it's
made it submit and said I'll be good and
so far it's been good but uh so yes to
answer that question February 25th I was
just in Los Angeles
um all week uh I had to leave the fat
man
um on Batman screening that we had for
19 and Batman on Sunday uh my
mother-in-law Gail the amazing Gail
Stanley Jen's mom
uh was very she got very sick and uh we
had she had to go to the hospital it was
it was scary touch and go
um but because of that I I I was home
for a nice stretch and whatnot and uh I
saw that that Babylon show was coming up
because I was like oh yes that's
happening uh it's been almost five years
since the [ __ ] heart attack five
years ago I could have died Mark and I
could have lost so much I would have
missed Jay and Silent Bob reboot clerks
three you know I I don't want to say
this because
um well I would have missed Masters the
universe
[Music]
no all right
um yeah I would have missed a lot of
[ __ ] man a lot of [ __ ] wouldn't miss my
kid get in the house like [ __ ]
so yeah it's a big it's a Big Show kids
tickets at cspod.com if you're into that
sort of thing or go to the flappers
website Meanwhile we're selling tickets
on the other side of the country son
here at smart Castle Cinemas where I sit
at the very top of
um we've been selling out crazy shows we
got a mallrat screening coming up on uh
March no March January 20th sold out
with Jeremy London and Jason Lee both in
attendance
um and then remember I've been talking
about ever since I've been talking about
the movie theater I was like we're gonna
do a thing called clerks open all night
and we're gonna show all three clerks
movies from 11 30 at night till six in
the morning do a lock-in you come in
your pajamas and [ __ ] and when I say
come in your pajamas you I'm I'm not
even being Physicians I mean come in
your pajamas
um that's sold out I thought we'd sell
50 to 100 tickets to that but sold the
[ __ ] out man tonight Friday the 13th
tomorrow Iron Man
um yeah I'm having a blast bro I'm I'm
that's why I can't wait for the odds of
Mark uh it's gonna be good times good
times and and there may be
I'm not I can't publicize it but I can't
we can't sell on it we can't tantalize
it even really can't even really tease
it
but there may be a little something some
at the end of that fat man beyond that
we do that Saturday night oh I ain't got
to tell them but I know what it is
a little something something
um there was somebody I don't know if it
was here
on the last show no I don't think it was
but somebody somewhere was like hey you
should do a series of cop movies and
call it popcorn and popcorn
it's a legit [ __ ] great idea isn't it
a great name
I mean only because of the rhyme yeah
absolutely but the idea of cop porn is
like you know [ __ ]
what would be like the five best cop
movies like Dirty Harry's got to be one
of them right not Dirty Harry but Sudden
Impact where he goes go ahead make my
day yeah you know
I mean if you want I was gonna say
French Connection I was gonna say bullet
I was gonna say Serpico Nighthawks yeah
how come what about all the movies where
they're wearing blue like most of the
cops in my neck of the woods they all
wear blue they're not like being dressed
like Serpico so what are the two top
movies
the good like cops on a beat movies
Die Hard of course it's a [ __ ] there
you go greatest cop movies of all time
somebody just suggested one I didn't
even think of a few people are saying it
I'm pretty dumb cop out Mark
yeah that is don't say it like that like
yeah
qualify like a more supportive yeah
I mean yeah good idea cop out I can
finally get people to watch it and [ __ ]
um Lethal Weapon like that's got to be
one of them right but sure
but there are not a ton of like boys in
blue like that is because they're not
that exciting as dramatic protagonists
hammer for uh 3528 chat said colors
there's a movie where they're wearing
the Blues
sure
um
Training Day number one says Cobra
Training Day what a great choice
yeah the gun audit The Departed
qualifies Hot Fuzz says Joe Hart great
[ __ ] Choice the depotted absolutely
[ __ ] counts man we got some good
choices super now here's the RoboCop son
I can't believe it took this long for
somebody to [ __ ] a RoboCop now with this
Festival you know it's just basically a
series of cool cop movies that maybe you
haven't seen on the big screen in a
while
all cops get in free
that's that's got to be the hook for for
popcorn and popcorn right yeah I mean I
would also
you get in free I would also say maybe
donate some of the proceeds to the legal
defense fund
laughs
Mark let's balance this a little
good call it's good call oh my God
somebody said Bad Lieutenant [ __ ] yes oh
[ __ ] yes
Paul McMichael said chips
yeah yeah
oh my God how are we missing it Marco
Ramos
Beverly Hills Cop
Banff who wouldn't want to [ __ ] with
Beverly Hills Cop on a big screen go Bam
Bam Police Academy
oh did you say that
because he's looking for boys in blue
and and that I think was it I mean I'm
not necessarily you know it could be a
spectrum of course of colors but um I
did want to get some uniform when I
think of cop I think of
wearing the blue not necessarily like
you know [ __ ] Martin Riggs in
Lethal Weapon
do you want to jump
do you wanna
I got nothing better to do I haven't
seen that movie in a long time
I think it holds up
is it
bam lethal yes New Jack City that counts
mm-hmm
Danny Glover in Lethal Weapon I believe
is my age by the way
you shut the [ __ ] up he's like getting
too old for this [ __ ] he's I think 42
when he filmed that movie
wow uh Super Troopers has been suggested
a couple times
Maniac Cop holy [ __ ] Carl Urban Judge
Dredd good choice and a good movie too
it's very much like the raid but still a
really good movie I mean the raid
they're actually all cops and they're
most of them are in uniform that's true
the raid Paul McMichael said Kevin I was
in Police Academy too when I was 10
years old I did my scene with Howard
Hessman
the [ __ ] famous people in our chat
tonight bro oh Paul Blart Mall Cop I
don't know does that count
I mean I don't even get Kevin James only
if you could get Kevin James to show up
and do a q a with it
that would be Observe and Report that's
a good one good choice I mean not
technically cop but still
Samurai cup
um
you know boy that was fun thanks for all
your suggestions kids that's going to be
easy to put together I've gotten there's
a record
I I'll give you one if you guys want to
do it out there we were gonna do it it's
coming villainy we probably still will
because we can show movies in the bar we
were going to do the hard as a rock
series and it's all movies with either
hard or Rock in the title so like die
hard hard target Hard to Kill the Rock
with Nicholas Cage and it's all those
like very 80s early 90s like Macho Van
Damme type movies oh could you do Rock
of Ages too
you probably it would fit within the
guidelines I don't know thematically if
that makes a lot of sense but rock and
roll a friend of mine Janet Peterson
just texted me one word and I was like
what and then I think it's because she's
watching the show Fargo
she's a cop she's she's a large son of a
Gunderson she's a legit one of the
greatest movie cops of all time
crazy
um boy oh boy you hell or high water
yes because Jeff Jeff Bridges he's the
cop and he's in uniform for most of that
movie he is in most of the movie
what somebody say School of Rock no cops
in that movie is there I think that's
for JC's heart is a rock Marathon
you you love uh Canada what about Dudley
Do-Right
in a heartbeat
and also like my man's back mm-hmm
it's sweet it's [ __ ]
my actor's Roundtable has over a million
views right now I mean
um
Brendan Fraser
uh Adam Sandler Austin Butler and Colin
Farrell
um Austin did [ __ ] were you like hey
bro
I didn't I didn't get into it because I
was busy
like directing the show but I I wanted
all right all right [ __ ] bragger some
of us can direct and do other things at
the same time you have a lot more
experience than I do so
uh what how much of the for those that
don't know uh Banff man
Works uh with um
well it works with us but he gets paid
by [ __ ] dollars
um and he does those like actor and
actress round tables director round
tables and every time they sit five or
six [ __ ] together and they're talking
JC usually behind it and stuff how much
like did they shoot versus what they
keep like what's the ratio we try to
shoot
an hour and cut it down to just shy of
an hour with actor I think
some of them run long
um with actor I think it was an hour and
25 minutes and we cut it down to like
58.
I mean [ __ ] the chat's on fire with
suggestions Running Scared one of my
favorite [ __ ] qualities of all time
with uh Gregory Hines and [ __ ] uh
Billy Crystal who are we going to get to
play Chicago's toughest detectives I
know a tiny Jewish comedian and a black
tap dancer
let's go still that movie works the
Naked Gun
from the files of police squad
The Untouchables Jesus
I mean five movies how the [ __ ] I'm
Gonna Keep It Down
um that's what she said yeah okay
well watch them Golden Globes at all
clothes
Goldie gloves
um I did watch it I uh I was I was
happiest for
um the everything everywhere all at once
crew
to watch Michelle yo and kihu Kwan win
awards for that stuff and like you Quan
won an award sure a supporting actor for
him he's good and it's a lovely speech
it's just a lovely speech because
Spielberg is sitting in the audience
nominated for the Fable men's and it was
like that man gave me my first job
like it's the only reason I'm here is
because he started my career as as Short
Round in Indiana Jones don't make me cry
not this year mark we want to break that
scene I'm not crying on the internet no
more [ __ ] they they've ruined it for
me so I'm certainly not gonna post
pictures of myself crying so don't make
me [ __ ] inadvertently Cry by telling
me a beautiful story about
[ __ ] Short Round recognizing Steven
Spielberg yeah and then I I have to
imagine that I think the reason why JC's
actors Roundtable is blowing up is
because all of the kihu Quan stuff has
become viral like it's all kind of
gotten a life of its own because that
narrative is so strong you know like he
it's been 40 years since that dude has
been in a movie and this is his comeback
you know wait wait wait what 40 years
it's been 40 years since since uh
Indiana Jones the Temple of Doom I think
yeah what about Goonies he was in
Goonies right that was the start of his
career but that's okay I'll give him 30
years since the last time he worked it's
um there's a really nice by the way I
think it's doing well because of my
direction not so much the people who are
on the panel yeah
but there's a really nice moment towards
the end uh where Brendan Fraser talks
they talk about he uh kihu Kwan was an
Encino Man and he they they have this uh
little moment where they're like we've
we're still here we're still doing this
all these years later it's very sweet
like Brendan was crying
yeah how come he don't get [ __ ] beat
up by everybody he cries a lot too just
like me I guess he don't post pictures
that's the difference I love how
emotionally gets man he's a good [ __ ]
dude
um like I'm happy he's having this
[ __ ] second moment because let's not
forget like this guy is [ __ ] he was
in the mummy movies and those movies
were huge yeah they were massive
um and when he was his absolute biggest
with the mummy movies man I ran into him
at the I've told the story before I ran
into it but at least it's not my heart
attack story somebody in [ __ ] chat
was like Kevin I love you but stop
talking about your heart attack [ __ ] you
no I'm not gonna stop talking about my
heart attack particularly when I'm
answering a question about [ __ ]
Hollywood Babylon show that is all about
the heart attack so
God people are so pushy aren't they
um
what was I just talking about Brendan
French you met Brendan Fraser during the
mummy I ran into him I was at the Four
Seasons in New York and uh you know I've
never met him before and [ __ ] but it was
me and my wife and my kid and my and my
in-laws Byron and Gill
we were getting off an elevator and he
was getting on an elevator and this is
at the height like mummy maybe mummy two
Mummy Returns whatever the [ __ ] so you
know he's [ __ ] super famous
and
he uh like held the guy out of the
elevator and then he did a double take
and held the door and he was like Kevin
how are you and I was like great man how
are you nice to meet you he's like nice
to meet you uh is this your family like
he was so [ __ ] like my that
elevator's door is closed and my [ __ ]
family looked at me like
how do you know the [ __ ] mommy guy
I was like I don't I don't I don't he's
just he's raised well he's so polite uh
and then I ran into him for Louisa I
think I told this story too
um I was at one of the fan Expos and
um there was he was sitting at a table
um you know in the green room and there
was a woman sitting right next to him
and stuff so I went over and I was like
man I like I'm sorry to interrupt I like
I I know
if I was truly sorry I would have been
not interrupted in the first place but
like I just wanted to say man hey like
years ago and I told I just literally
told Brandon that story
and
and you know and I turned to the woman I
was like I'm so sorry like I'm
interrupting
pressure goes Kevin I don't know who
that is she's just also sitting at the
table
they weren't together I thought they
were and I was like oh my God I'm so
sorry
um he's such a sweet [ __ ] dude and at
that moment in time he was like Firefly
in uh the Batgirl movie so I was I was
quizzing him about that and [ __ ] and he
said the directors were wonderful and he
said that uh the actors was wonderful
um and then months later well a year
later is when maybe not a year six eight
months later
no background movie anyway the uh the
since we're talking about good people uh
one Colin Farrell for as much crap as
he's gotten his whole career was the
nicest person ever
so so genuine yeah he's great guy I met
him on uh Daredevil back in the day the
other Daredevil Ben Affleck Daredevil
um yeah yeah he was a good dude man
really good dude um
sexy too yeah
uh also like my age and I'm like how do
what is what am I what is going on he's
younger than me he's 44 I believe we're
45 he said
wow yeah I mean that's a game we should
not play with famous people
like you're just Alba and I are the same
age which
no no like I just don't know how you
have to bathe in like berries and milks
from Virgin goats or some [ __ ] Lazarus
Pit yeah like I don't I don't know how
he achieves that and here I am with this
do you see a picture I don't know you
know I forget where it was it popped up
in some news feed but not
what was it Jacqueline Smith not Kate
Jackson one of the original Angels
Jacqueline Smith
who's like 186 or whatever she ain't
that old but she's like in her 70s or
80s and like should look it
and does not looks like still looks like
a Charlie's Angel like
and and there's photos of her and her
husband like working out sexy working
out in the yard and he's like picking
her up and he's like he's younger than
her but he's still an old man
and I was like
what what's wrong with me is it genetics
like
how do you stay eternally young like
that I mean Angela Bassett is 64 years
old what
and she was on the Golden Globes like
looking like she's 42.
I don't get it again I suppose eating
well personal trainers like
all of that helps but then there's just
oh you were just born with better genes
than mine
Max Flay and chat pointed out Linda
Carter yeah Linda Carter is aged
insanely well yeah
I want some of that man I want some of
that look let me ask you this you see an
avatar right
if you got to drill into a whale's brain
steal his brain just keep you young
would you do it
spoilers
spoilers that don't actually mean
anything to the movie
would you would you do it I mean I
haven't really thought about it since it
happened in the movie I think when it
was happening in the movie the first
second I was like
you know I love living things but
looking young forever
yeah it is a weird thing in that movie
where it's like the centerpiece of a
massive section in the movie that bears
no impact whatsoever on the rest of the
movie no
um but yeah I mean if I had the money
sure
Dan of Earth says what about William
Shatner dudes in his 90s you'd never
know [ __ ] truth man like when he you
know he's uh
yeah they yeah they announced he's in
Masters of the Universe they just
haven't said what he's playing every
once in a while I'm such a stoner I
forget a lot of people know and what
they don't know I was like wait am I
spoiling something but he's come to do
uh voiceover and always drives himself
always drives you know like he's
piloting his [ __ ] Starship like like
he's the young Captain here and Brooks
know
fools and wants like
hey man don't waste my time I'm 92.
like he puts it right on Front Street
but he but he you're right he's he looks
very he don't look 92. dude looks like
he's in his 70s
yeah I mean on the other side of that is
did you see the trailer it dropped today
for history of the World Part Two
what yeah
Hulu is doing a mini series called
history of the World Part Two and it's
introduced by Mel Brooks at 96 years old
and Mel like I think it's that he's
looked 96 for the last 20 years
wait wait wait
[ __ ] all that are we seriously getting
history of the World Part Two yeah
did you not know this
no
ever since I was a child I wanted to see
Jews in space we were promised at the
end of the movie remember
so it will be done oh my God that's that
what a long con that has been [ __ ] talk
about
stick in the land and closing the
[ __ ] Circle seriously did he make it
um I think he's he's involved with it
but I think it's a Nick Kroll kind of
over saw it all and kind of was the
shepherd creatively behind it
but yeah they've been edging us for 40
years now
I saw history of the World Part One
eight times in a movie theater as a kid
that movie was perfect for like a 9 to
11 year old whatever [ __ ] remember
speaking of Gregory Hines remember this
is a pirates they're all eunuchs and
then the girl dances and you know in
front of each unit nothing happens and
his feather goes all the way up
it's a good ass movie man yeah that's
maybe we should have a Mel Brooks thing
going on especially knowing that when's
that come out uh I'm not sure I mean
it's relatively soon let me check and
see Pub um Spartan wrote in chat is it
strange that Mel Brooks produced The Fly
uh no Mel I mean it is I guess kind of
weird but like there is a period of time
where he produced a lot of movies
including
uh The Elephant Man David Legend he
produced that and then
absolutely he did movies that weren't
like just goofy ass comedies but yeah he
produced the fly as well
bamf can can I ask a question about
owning a movie theater
oh my God you've got the guy right here
I but I think it's interesting right and
hopefully I'm not the only one
Fantastic Four inches pointed out in
chat Jews in space was Spaceballs
indeed and it's out in March History of
the World War II on Hulu I'm [ __ ]
there oh my God I'm getting a completing
a part of my childhood back to you
Batman so when you're like you know what
let's do a Marvel thing or a Batman or a
Mel Brooks
these are old movies you don't just like
buy them on iTunes and Screen them right
do you have to like call a studio or
like how does it and then get permission
and then give them a portion of ticket
sales or do you pay a thousand dollars
to show the movie and hope you can sell
more tickets
on the low end and then generally for
older movies it's low end is 300
um to rent the title or whatnot
um there's also a version you could do
that's like percentage of gate and stuff
but generally speaking
um it's it's that it's on the it's on
the lower end like 300 bucks so you know
then the idea is you just gotta make
300 and ticket sales because then you'll
make out with concessions
yeah I mean that's the Dirty Little
Secret of the movie business is like you
know we got Avatar playing
and Avatar has here
would you like to hear some [ __ ] data
oh he's got numbers I do I got some
[ __ ] numbers man let me see hold on
Ernie
um
I'm always bugging Ernie asking like
what's the count and all the ticket
sales and stuff so Ernie starts sending
me the charts that show you what tickets
have sold over the course of the life of
the movie theater okay
so
Avatar the way of water
as of last week
we have sold
338 tickets total
total now our biggest we're five screen
Multiplex and our biggest screen is it
seats 230.
so
Avatar the biggest [ __ ] undeniably
biggest movie of the year those thus far
has sold 338 tickets for a grand total
of
2932 dollars
and 80 of that goes back to the studio
um would you like to hear what a New
Year's evening with Kevin Smith made
now mind you we only sold 221 tickets
that but that's a sellout for that
theater compared to Avatar's 338.
uh they made 2 900 bucks so far uh for
one night for that screening uh we made
14
000 bucks
uh the key here is just overcharge
that's it it's no secret
they're asking for 10 bucks forever so
I'm asking for 37 to come see me
um Fat Man on Batman film club man like
we had a 181 people
come uh push Puss and Boots the lot the
last wish
um is the second best movie playing at
our theater
historically you know for for its life
life of the Run we have sold 309 tickets
to that total since puss and boots came
out
um and made a grand total of 24 hundred
dollars
uh the Fable men's has sold a grand
total of 182 tickets
since coming to smodcast Castle
um and we've made fourteen hundred
dollars
so I I you know I honestly don't I as I
went across country like Babylon has
sold 107 tickets for a grand total of
918 total I
I went across the country of course with
the you know smod with uh clerks through
the convenience store so I was in a lot
of like Mom and Pop movie theaters and
uh you know big ones that got like
thousand seaters and [ __ ]
but still mom and pop oriented not like
AMC or [ __ ] like that every one of them
was just like you can't survive as a
movie theater without a liquor license
like you have a liquor license I was
like not yet they're like can't survive
on selling popcorn not in this day and
age that's why most movie theaters have
bars in them at this point how much do
you sell popcorn for
like what's the margin on popcorn it's
pretty good right it's got dollars a
bucket yeah
37 a month
um the popcorn which we pop fresh we
don't like bring in bags and [ __ ] like
that some places do that we just make
our popcorn
um I don't know I've never bought a
popcorn
to be fair I don't even eat the popcorn
because I haven't asked if it's vegan or
not some people like how could it not be
vegan well if you use like you know
animal but animal oil like
you know that [ __ ] whatever [ __ ] get off
my dick
um
ask ask more questions about owning a
movie theater
I think I'm out
that's it I was interested in the
margins on popcorn and Candy because I'm
like I mean I know what they are for
liquor right yeah so maybe so it might
be a good team up but
um but I guess you would buy you might
buy like three
cocktails but you're only gonna buy one
bucket of popcorn right and is that the
maybe the idea
yes because I got a cocktail
if if it's like a Buck 50 in ingredients
you're probably charging like 11 12
bucks for the car I know believe me
that's why we're trying to get into the
[ __ ] liquor business because one
bottle of booze you know you'll get like
hundreds of dollars out of it's so uh
inside
baseball and I shouldn't say this
because no everybody's gonna not come
out anymore but Tracy don't don't do it
I'm gonna be the guy who says don't give
it away because people will say about it
every time I'll give you I'll I'll take
it outside of Skillman villain I went to
um
uh an NFL Rams game a few years ago and
we brought some friends with us and
they're like let me let me buy you a
beer let's get let me get you a Corona
and the Coronas for like a 16 ounce
Corona at at the stadium was like 25
bucks I was like I can't do it I can't
do it and he's like why just let me get
you the beer I was like I can't do it a
bottle of Corona at that time it's gone
up but at that time pre-pandemic was 70
cents for 12 ounces so they were selling
16 ounces for 25 bucks and and I'm like
I can get that exact same thing for like
a buck 10. and so that's the markup at
stadiums
where you go when you go and buy beer at
stadiums
it's um uh somebody's uh said uh Sound
Investment oh Dave bow9 you go Sound
Investment with a thumbs up
um normally it wouldn't be uh the only
reason I was uh like justifying buying a
movie theater was because I I know how
to make it earn in ways that
like normal movie theaters can't like
for example like we bring in
you know [ __ ] Jason Lee and and
Jeremy London and show Mallrats and
you know up charge or we just uh bring
in George RR Martin and do a show where
I do a show by myself
um so there's ways that I mean this is
going to sound I'm not bragging but like
in
first two months of ownership September
and October we made more than the
theater had made in the previous entire
year calendar year so
it is a Sound Investment if you you know
have other things to do at the theater
this has been a perfect blend for me you
know I've tried two other spot castles
before and the thing that was always
missing was the of you know movies like
you know it's a movie theater so even if
I'm here or not here movies got a movie
and people come to the movies all the
time and stuff not a lot as you've heard
but definitely enough to keep the lights
on and stuff then on top of that if you
could build you know what we've been
building which is like here's a fun
[ __ ] show and now it's sold out like
I'm seeing full houses in that [ __ ]
theater for the first time like since my
childhood and stuff so you know it would
have been just a vanity to buy a movie
theater if I couldn't make it earn
that's why I like you know for
everyone's like why are you in Jersey so
much because I bought a [ __ ] movie
theater and I'm trying to make it or not
I know exactly how to do that but I got
to be there for it I can't be like hey
man go to the movie theater where I'm
not you know that's the one thing I
could bring to it and it's uh it's
happened at a good time in my life
because my kids all grown up and [ __ ]
like that so it's not like I got to be
around California as much and this is
fun for me I [ __ ] enjoy the [ __ ] out
of this like I I enjoy like coming up
with a program and like selling tickets
for it and [ __ ] like that it's
well and you see what works right and
what doesn't and then you can adjust
it's like a very
uh it's not like doing some giant
production where you're like we gotta go
all in in this direction and hope it
works like you can adjust
day by day almost in
you know a a 200 percent increase in
sales is is very much doable versus like
you make a movie and
it either has a 10 million dollar
opening weekend or it doesn't
you know
um somebody said you got to do the Rocky
Horror Picture Show they do that over in
Red Bank I felt kind of like I didn't
want to bite onto their thing
um they over at uh the Count Basie
theaters in Red Bank
so I you know naturally of course I was
like oh my God we could do it but while
they're doing it I don't really want to
you know [ __ ] I don't know I won't be
that guy
do a bunch of other cool stuff I don't
need to you know be like hey and we're
doing The Rocky Horror Picture Show I
mean there's more stuff like it makes
more sense like to do like our anybody
want a peanut that we're gonna do here
for you which is Princess Bride meets
Rocky Horror Picture Show than it does
to do like that's more on brand right
yes that's such a good idea such a great
[ __ ] title too
um somebody pointed out Tyler Hall said
what about Lebowski Fest
um sure
do they come to you or are you just
saying have a Lebowski Fest of my own
um yeah I'm I'm game for a lot of things
it's just fun time somebody asked about
playing video games there Jason wants to
do that Jason Muse
um you know just game because he's he's
always on Twitch streaming on Twitch so
he wants to uh no I'm good thank you he
wants to um like game pets podcast on
the [ __ ] screen and then have people
playing and [ __ ] and I was like you know
he's probably talking about fortnite or
[ __ ] like that but in my head I was like
oh yeah [ __ ] centipede like Pac-Man
thinking of old [ __ ] old ass games
and stuff but yeah it's it's a good time
so we're like oh [ __ ] my light went up
it's back
um anyway enough about that [ __ ] [ __ ]
shall we talk about the subject in hand
shall we finally get into the news we
can do the news absolutely let's do it
man Mark Bernard used to be an old news
hound kids
and now he's an award-winning [ __ ]
writer he tells Tales they're not
fact-based anymore but back in the day
there's a fact-based journalist man and
once you've once a journal always a
journal you can take the boy out of
[ __ ] The Hollywood Reporter but you
can't take the Hollywood Reporter out of
the boy and so Mark Bernardin still has
a nose for news and he's brought you the
news here he is
um a little quick box office hit
um even though Avatar continues to Reign
at the box office
um and continue to perform at every
place except for smodcast Castle uh by
the sound of it
that's our biggest ticket seller though
of the real movies 330 tickets that's
the you know he's the king of the world
here as well it's just the world very
small here it was very small here
um Megan opened apparently uh trouncing
the the estimates to 30 million dollars
and it's okay yeah that played here that
did well for us yeah um I saw Megan uh
even though I am not a traditional
horror person I've I've exclaimed it uh
far and wide horror is not at least
modern horror is not my jam but uh but I
have a personal connection to the movie
in that I know the woman who wrote it
um friend of the show akayla Cooper
um she's been a guest on black man
Beyond in the past and so I went out to
support my friend and I had a really
[ __ ] good time well today man yeah
like it's it's campy and it's silly and
it's got a couple good jump scares and
um it has something to say about sort of
the the disaffection of Parenthood and
the disconnection of children and all of
that stuff but overall man I just
[ __ ] enjoyed myself
and got to got to give a friend her
flowers which was lovely
um is there Justin Roiland news
there is Justin Roiland
um apparently is I don't know exactly
the legal terms for what's going on but
I think there was an arraignment about a
a sexual assault charge against him
um
I would have to look it up and get much
more of the details but it is not good
just in royalland news if that's the
thing that you were looking for moving
on somebody in the chat said something
about royland
um
all right back to you
um so yes Megan opened incredibly well
there's already talk about a sequel I'm
hoping it is an army of Megan's
um that that take over the world because
that's just me was it uh you know I'm
not saying oh it [ __ ] I'm not
reducing it but it there is a bit of
Child's Play to it right could there be
one day down the line a Chucky versus
Megan crossover yeah absolutely I said
it wrong
um yes I mean it it's it is 100 a killer
doll movie you know and there's a long
lineage of killer doll movies of which
Chucky is probably the the king of said
killer dolls but I started the Alamo
Drafthouse and if you've ever been to a
Draft House you know that they do
customize and curate an opening show
before every movie and so it was a good
15 minutes of various [ __ ] killer
doll movies going as far back as evil
mannequins on the Twilight Zone to
Chucky [ __ ] to deadly friend to there's
been there's there's been a deadly
friend is a deep Cuts Wes Craven picture
that's a deep cut Wes Craven but that
was kind of wonderful
um to see young Christy Swanson try to
fight an evil doll
wow uh how uh so you like this Megan
picture I dug it I dug it I mean it's
it's it is deeper than it needed to be
for what it is
um and Allison Williams is is quite good
at it I think she's found her she's
found her her sweet spot
which is kind of like awful white lady
who maybe takes a turn towards the good
or maybe doesn't
like he doesn't is in get out where
she's just hey I was gonna say that's
not what happened to get out
but here she learns it was really good
in that movie actually and get out yeah
like she I didn't I didn't watch girls
so I'm not familiar with her work
um there but I I thought she was really
great and get out yeah you know and she
it seems like she's got a fairly decent
head on her shoulders because she's she
has been navigating the same
um you know tide pool of nepo baby
accusations that everybody else who's
got a particularly famous father
who's uh who's her dad Brian Williams
NBC News
um does that really count like is that
like news division it's not in these
she's in a news division but he was the
face of NBC news for a very long while
and so in New York circles that gets you
something you know that that gets you
access to things that most people don't
have access to
um
Dairy no one
would a
Wi-Fi emoji and says Mark liked it
work like stuff I do occasionally like
things
I don't live in this chamber of hatred
it's just like bring me a new thing to
disembowel
doesn't live in a chamber of hatred he
just sleeps in it
then he wakes up and spreads the eight
and then goes back to his name like Boba
Fett in a back to tank of hatred and it
makes me whole again and then I go back
into my life
uh but yes so Megan if you have not seen
um I I I do recommend you go have a good
time
um the latest on Superman and Batman and
DC films uh new DC co-boss James Gunn
um has you know done the thing that he
seems to be doing which is going on
Twitter to debunk things
um he's debunked a rumor that they've
already cast Superman for the new
iteration of the Man of Steel
um the most recent Fanboy reports was
that a guy from uh Euphoria had been
cast
and uh Mr Gunn went on Twitter and said
my thoughts are that no one has been
cast as Superman yet casting is almost
always as is almost always the case with
me will happen after the script is
finished or close to finish and it isn't
um you'll announce a few things in not
too long but the casting of Superman
won't be one of them
so no Superman yet still writing a
script
I like how James is
like just
being his own publicist for the entire
DC Warner Brothers division whatever it
is like it's smart everybody should be
like as accountable as he is you know I
know a lot of people are like I don't
like what he's doing but it's like at
least he's answering questions he's not
hiding yeah and he's not being shitty
about it like where he's like [ __ ]
everything you like he's like look we're
just doing a thing and you know I'm
sorry if that hurts some people's
feelings but like you know I respect the
fact that he's answering questions he
doesn't have to like you know how often
does anybody at Marvel go like all right
let's address the fans concerns don't
really happen no
um I mean at some point I have to
imagine that you know Warner Brothers PR
at some point will be like Hey listen
you've done a great job so far champ but
listen we're gonna take this boat away
from you at this point because we want
to control the message a little bit
better than this
um while it was all new and raw and wet
dirt it made sense but now you got to be
more fighty and less you know guy on
internet shouts at Clouds let me tell
you something we all got to be more
foggy if we could all be just a little
more foggy this would be such a better
world
that's the only cabin that matters in
this world as far as I'm concerned my
mom agrees
and she [ __ ] gave birth to Kevin but
she's like look push comes to shove we
need foggy she's like you we've seen
clerks three you're done
I'm like well you haven't seen his
Ant-Man what about the [ __ ] new
Ant-Man trailer it looks good man it's
gonna look good it doesn't look like
something bad is going to happen I'm so
down for this this feels like I'm not
gonna say like it's The Empire Strikes
Back but it feels like it has a dark
ending like and since we know Kang's
gonna stick around for a while
I I don't know man I think this might be
the one I mean yeah given that they
cannot defeat the bad guy exactly
um it does seem that there may be some a
body count to this particular Ant-Man
um I did enjoy seeing a little bit of
Modoc if you and not just Modoc the
metal face but also big face Modoc like
that metal face version looks like it's
his armor or mask but
who is it does anybody know is it carry
stole I read online somebody theorized
that it was going to be yellow jacket oh
interesting yeah I don't know why but
and I can't be a spoiler because I just
read it online and [ __ ] they didn't say
it was I think it was their
their guess Rumor Mill Rumor Mill is at
work
um but yeah no it looks I mean the the
one thing that if I had to complain
about and because it's me I probably
will is that
Ant-Man
the the gag of Ant-Man is that he gets
small and everything else around him is
big
and then but once you put him in like
outer space and like interdimensional
[ __ ] where I have no real frame of
reference then his size is no longer the
gag
and so then what is like suddenly it
becomes what what do you what do you do
anymore you just get small what does
small mean when everything is smaller
when everything is big or when you're in
the quantum realm or whatever that is
um I have faith that they have some
answer to it but just from from the the
the month and a half out View
it's like I don't know what that is but
okay all right if you're gonna bring
some trauma and some tragedy to Ant-Man
I'll give you my 15 bucks to see what
that looks like
Sasquatch Jenkins and chat
never thought I'd say that
um said they can defeat them they can
defeat the bad guy there are infinite
Kang variants
so he could [ __ ] beat this Kang and
they'll be might be there's gonna be
another king and Jonathan Majors says
yeah has said that he's playing multiple
versions of this character
multiple means more than two
you know and similarly somebody could
die here a hero could fall
that then gets resurrected or a variant
version of shows up for the Kang Dynasty
or the secret Wars or whatever it is
um so maybe nothing sticks or maybe
something does
we'll see what happens reshoots this
week somebody I saw an article
which they were like that's the closest
to a release Marvel's ever done reshoots
I doubt that's true yeah I mean they
they shot the final scene of Avengers
the day before the premiere
when they're in the shawarma place
is that right yeah
it was either the day before the
premiere or just after the premiere
because that was when they would get
everybody back in town and Chris Evans
as Steve Rogers is just sitting like
this the whole time because he still had
a beard on and so that was the only way
they could hide the beer that he didn't
want to shave to shoot that ending so
like the the prints have been wet on the
way to the theater before
um what else we got
um meanwhile
um Batman director Matt Reeves uh in a
sit down with collider revealed that
he's expected to meet with Gunn and and
fellow co-ceat DC boss Peter saffron the
next couple of weeks to unveil
um both the DC bosses idea for the next
eight to ten years of the the DC
Universe and what the bat verse is going
to be for the next uh the next few few
iterations
um and it's kind of their own thing like
Reeves I had a dream for this way I
wanted to play out and that's part of
what I'm going to be talking to them
about in a few weeks they're going to be
talking to me about what they're doing
in their 10-year plan and uh and so we
can understand what what we're doing and
they can understand what we're doing so
it's Air Traffic Control we don't want
to be crashing into each other we want
to support each other I'm super excited
I'm really excited to hear about what
they're doing and to be working with
them it's going to be cool Reeve said
um so it seems as if whatever's
happening the bat is going to be its own
separate discrete fit
it may or may not glance against what
the main DC idea is but it doesn't seem
as if it's cohesive in the same way that
they're sticking to the elseworlds idea
right
I like that I like else worlds I was
there for the very first one
and they've published a elseworld's book
it's cool that's cool concept which
means I mean there's also a version
it's it would be complicated for an
audience I think and again we're living
in a varying world where people will be
getting different versions of Marvel
heroes that Robert Pattinson plays
Batman both in the Matt Reeves bat
universe and in the main Prime DC
Universe just a different version of
Batman
that version could be a little bit
brighter could be a little bit less emo
goth you know might crack a smile or two
possible all things are possible you
want to hear what somebody thinks is
going to happen at the end of man theory
Sure
I don't remember kids it's just theories
from
bran Nick Ant-Man will die in the end to
prevent Kang's Escape but Kang will
escape and post credits and Ant-Man will
be presumed dead until showing back up
in secret Wars where he will be the key
to winning
if that was it
I'm I'm [ __ ] tickled I hope that's it
I hope that's it
I can't wait to see what it is you see
the uh yes
speaking of James Gunn he is also
writing but somebody in chat said
spoiler that's not a [ __ ] spoiler if
somebody's
guess picking it up yeah
back to you
um elsewhere in James Gunn news
um he tweeted a week or so ago that he
wrote one third of an unannounced DC TV
show
um nobody's explaining exactly what it
is
um given that he is still yet you know
apparently it's about a month off
unveiling what the ongoing plan is going
to be
um
he did talk about there being a not just
a peacemaker season two which is coming
um but a peacemaker spin-off series
um the Viola Davis Amanda Waller series
which will pick up where John Cena ends
I think those are two different things
it's unclear if this unannounced TV show
is that or if it's a completely
different new third thing
but James Gunn is the busiest head of a
production company I've ever heard of
yeah yeah
but and also his output is making me
feel insignificant yeah he yeah he's
prolific to say the least man heavens
uh bearded villain says John Hamm is
Batman I 100 percent
100 agree
let's all go and tell Warner Brothers
let's all tell James Gunn
we all want bad hand
I am
just looks like a superhero doesn't he
does he does indeed
um speaking of people who should be
superheroes yeah even Carlo Esposito is
Zito
bugging out bugging out indeed the star
of Kaleidoscope on Netflix is he in that
have you watched I I haven't and my my
my hesitancy is only because
I don't know how to watch it
apparently you can watch them in any
order and that feels wrong to me I would
like a Storyteller to tell me how I'm
supposed to watch their story and so if
it's just open to interpretation that
way I feel a little like so come on so
give me and I've heard that there's
various versions there's an order that
gives it chronological as an order that
gives it according to whatever there's
I don't I don't know I don't know I'm
afraid
it is um
you know ver it seems like one of the
most Netflix
um
kind of movies or series there is like
you know oh it could be watched in any
order it's like man
that feels like a Netflix thing yeah you
know and like they did that with love
death robots where it would serve
different viewers different orders of
episodes so if I said I just watched the
third one that might be the eighth
episode for somebody else might be the
first episode for somebody else but
that's a mythology it was not a building
story so I'm like all right whatever I
guess but I need I somebody got a road
map me a little bit on Kaleidoscope
um but at any rate Neil and chat the
zapro of nothing said would you give a
shout out to my father Bill we lost him
New Year's Eve he was a huge Star Wars
and Star Trek fan smoke one up for him
why Neil
I never I thought you'd never ask
I believe that this is for bill for
Father Bill not a priest my new dad bill
hey Batman I have a question about the
Netflix thing if if this show is
designed that you can watch it in any
order
isn't it similar to and I'm not saying
Quentin Tarantino does this but Pulp
Fiction was was edited out of sequence
so is it conceivable that the
screenwriter actually wrote it
so that each piece like it the the way
things are revealed is similar to like a
Quentin Tarantino movie where you get
the beginning at the end and the end in
the middle and the
you know and and it's all wonky that way
and they just figured out a way how to
piece these six episodes together that
it
it just kind of plays that same way
um in chat are wix123 said Arrested
Development season four didn't they do a
similar thing where it's like you could
watch it in any order it didn't matter
I mean technically most sitcoms you can
watch in any order and it doesn't matter
um
but it's it's I I don't quite understand
the virtue of that
um you know like yes there there's
something to be said for the Pulp
Fiction of it which is like oh yeah all
right I'm discovering context for things
that happened earlier and jokes that had
been seeded before are not coming to pay
off like all that stuff I make sense
it's a intentional diagrammatic plan but
they just yeah you could just roll dice
and watch them in that order you could
just [ __ ] like 52 pick up and figure
out how you wanted to to play it that's
just it's wonky to me
um you were a Last of Us person right I
am very much a Last of Us person have
you seen the trailer and do you like it
um I've seen the trailers
um they look they look big they look
good I have faith that a uh Craig Mason
who did Chernobyl
um will will lend the same level of of
Storytelling rigor and Greg Mason The
Artful writer The Artful writer the
co-host of the script notes podcast
um with John August
um but yeah like I'm I'm here for it and
I don't think that Naughty Dog which is
the company that produced a game
um given the importance of this title to
them would would Brook a shitty version
of this game as a TV show
um and I do like Pedro Pascal quite a
bit I keep waiting for him to Star on
the Burt Reynolds biopic that he's so
clearly destined to star in
um
because if you look at that dude you
look at Burt Reynolds it's like the same
man
is that right yeah
yeah
especially yeah oh God screw this said a
number of cool TV Riders saw The Last of
Us Premiere and are praising it to High
Heavens supposedly it's a game changer
yeah nobody nobody invites me to
premieres anymore
um
and the the reason the other reason why
I think it's probably good is that HBO
Max decided to increase their uh
subscription fee knowing that this was
going to be the reason people may or may
not stick around they went from 1495 to
1595 I think that takes effect in
February
uh which I find odd given how much [ __ ]
they're pulling off of HBO Max
like lots of old Sesame Street episodes
are not on the service anymore lots of
lots of episodes yeah Looney Tunes down
as well that's the Looney Tunes down you
know I mean I get why they're doing it
basically they've over explained it at
this point but it's so like
you know that seemed like everything all
in one place
like I like the idea that every Looney
Tunes was there now did I watch them all
[ __ ] no but like if I wanted to go find
him I knew where they were yeah yeah
a lesson and you know
um appreciate it while it's there
because it won't always be there object
the the lesson is also physical media
boys and girls if you buy it and you
have it in your hands they can't take it
away from you
if you really want it
buy it
Boston Samus said hey Kev talk about
your goatee I don't have a goatee
I got a beard
whole beard
yeah it's more of a Van Dyke than a and
again also goes oh well oh my God how
many times
I have nothing here Van Dyke would just
be there I got I got a Van Dyke like an
Oliver Queen
uh goatee is just this that's a soul
patch and [ __ ] like that
then there's this you know [ __ ] hey
Peter man when you just have the money
the Deidre Bader
two chicks
he's a [ __ ] genius I love DJ crater
uh what other news we got yes it's so
funny that the same guy who was like
it still is is actively Batman on the
Harley Quinn show uh I had started
talking about G and color Esposito and
then we found in a rabbit hole uh
Giancarlo Esposito uh is doubling down
on his desire to play Charles Xavier
I applaud this I think he would be great
Professor X I I was I'm gonna now I'm
gonna [ __ ] name drop and [ __ ] not
name drop but I'm gonna say that I know
him
um we were at a con one of these Fan
Expo cons recently and by the way hands
down best dressed person at any con will
always be Giancarlo Esposito [ __ ] like
always looks like he's coming from a
magazine shoot
uh but the day that the Professor X
story kind of like broke
um he rolled by he was like on his way
out you know from the floor from his
Booth or whatever and chit-chatted and I
was like is that true and he goes I hope
it is he's going I want that to be true
so badly I was like I think that's great
casting he was like I know he's gone
most people would expect me to play a
villain he's going but like you know
Professor X is complicated to say the
least he's a hero yes but like
there are nuances there and and man just
as he spoke about the character you can
tell he knew what the [ __ ] he was
talking about he wasn't just like hey
Marvel's hot I'll do that like
you knew like this is a character that I
could really knock out the park so I I
hope that'd be cool yeah I mean his his
quote from the stage of the tjh
superhero car show in Comic-Con in San
Antonio Texas
is uh I have not worked for Marvel yet
I've been in the room with him and I've
talked to them I'm gonna go for
something that's a little bit different
I'm gonna go out and put it into the
universe that I'd like to play Professor
X
Sasquatch Jenkins and chat says I would
love to see him play Doctor Doom and now
now I'm in love with that idea too oh my
God he would be an amazing guy look
point being give Giancarlo Esposito a
role whatever the [ __ ] he wants is one
of the greatest actors we got working
today yeah but I mean I think that
there's there's a certain amount of
Typecast that comes to him where like
he's great at bad guys so he only seems
to play Bad Guys between Gus Fring and
MAF Gideon and Stan Edgar and the boys
and like that's that's his whole move
which makes it so much more interesting
for me if he's suddenly he's playing the
hero and to your point a hero with
Shades a hero who's complicated a hero
who has done less than heroic things you
know and I don't know how they're going
to treat Jean Gray in this new X-Men but
what what Charles Xavier does to Jean
Gray is monstrous
um and so to have an actor who can find
that depth of of of venality while also
presenting as your hero I think that's
just fascinating it becomes interesting
way more interesting to me than if it's
just
another wonderful guy who's always
played wonderful Heroes
um there are a bunch of people
theorizing that um Henry Cavill is going
to play Dr Doom did you was that a thing
that was floating out there smart idea
you know one of the incarnations is
beautiful underneath that mental Mass
it's vain he just has a tiny little Mark
that's why he wears the metal mask and
[ __ ] like Henry gavel is a beautiful man
they'd be smart to scoop him up man oh
my God
this would be good I don't know if that
is if there's any truth to that because
they haven't announced any fantastic
forecasting but
given that Superman is no longer on his
uh to-do list he's got a little bit of
bandwidth
um
Henry Cavill is Captain Britain says
Pablo hands down I mean yeah but
yeah yeah I would say I wouldn't say
hands down but like yeah I guess that's
it's obvious
Evan Fowler goes Henry Cavill should
play Bizarro
you're nuts man they're like he ain't
gonna be Superman no more because he's
gonna be Bizarro
um
dagnificent says Giancarlo is my Xavier
of Denzel plays Magneto [ __ ] I'd see
that movie
out of all that
um all right what else we got
um Dave Batista he of the yield Glass
Onion and the Beast Rabon fame
um says he's ready to move on from the
Guardians of the Galaxy and in a GQ
interview even though he says he's so
grateful for foreign loves Drax the
Destroyer
um he there's a sense of relief that uh
his time has uh said Destroyer will come
to a close with May 5th and guardians of
galaxy vol 3.
um
he said uh the court is working on the
film was it all Pleasant it was hard
playing that role the makeup process was
beating me down and I just don't know if
I would if I want Drax to be my legacy
it's a silly performance and I want to
do more dramatic stuff
um
and he's like honestly I could give a
[ __ ] about being a movie star I don't
live a great big glamorous life I live
in Tampa I don't care about the
spotlight I don't care about Fame I just
want to be a better actor I want respect
from my peers it's about the experience
about knowing that I accomplished
something
um which you know like power to him man
I think that that that that the good
actors come to that point in their life
in their career where they they look at
the work they've been doing and they
want to kind of level up I think Tom
Cruise went through that phase you know
post Top Gun
um which you may or may not have seen
once
um and then started working with Martin
Scorsese and started working with Paul
Thomas Anderson they started making
really interesting movies with really
interesting directors and like [ __ ]
Stanley Kubrick because he wanted to
level up he wanted to work with the best
hoping that they would raise his game
and by all lies it did and so
for him to want to do that yeah I hear
it I understand it completely and he's
kind of on the way I mean [ __ ] he's
in Ryan Johnson is one of the best
filmmakers working today and he's in
Knives Out part two Glass Onion
dennyville news is one of the best
filmmakers working today and he's in two
parts of Dune
like he's already on apparently the
shortlist for some great directors and
so hell yeah more of that people a lot
of people pointing out that he's talked
about wanting to play Bane for a long
time
yeah you know I mean James Gunn likes
him clearly like if if
there's there's a ton of interesting
characters to be played in the DC
Universe
that might give him more to chew on than
Drax did
um talk for a second my mom just texted
me
um
I mean speaking of which I think he'd be
a very interesting choice as Swamp Thing
I would watch Dave Batista lean into
that
um yeah oh my God he does have the
dramatic chaps for a for a Swamp Thing
did it get darker in here yeah you hit
the light one more time it's getting
moody in here
[ __ ] smart bulbs in here and it's
really not that smart
it's like there's nobody here nobody's
moving I'm gonna turn off now
what
wow there's so much
life business
it is it's like a goddamn light show
well Josh Roush is here he'll [ __ ]
they'll put on a [ __ ] light show for
yeah look at that [ __ ] yeah I found a
[ __ ] cleague on that [ __ ]
um Josh Roush roushumon kids
January 25th to the 28th that's mod
Castle Cinemas come see wrong reasons uh
the movie uh that I produced
live stars in and produces and all the
documentaries those make why is it
getting dark anymore I'm trying to fix
it can't we just put like a an old style
bulb
whatever happened to tungsten lights
where's my filament
yes
word man you're right that don't happen
anymore the filament's gone it's all
it's like an LEDs baby it's all LED
these days
I want to hear some metal Sizzle
[ __ ]
um
maybe two more items what do you got
Stephen Amell is strapping on his Arrow
tights one last time for the uh for the
last season of The Flash
this is going to be they're not saying
what but I assume it's flashback stuff
and you're not bringing them back from
the dead are they
um
I guess they could because he runs real
fast and he can run through time and
[ __ ] he can run through time this is the
last season for the flash I think I mean
pun intended but they got a good run out
of that show
he's running CW Show
um I believe so I believe it out it out
it finally outpaced uh Arrow which was
the first
um but yeah so he's gonna return to
guest star in episode 909
um joining David Ramsey who's back is
John diggle and Kenny and Lonsdale as
Wally West and Kid Flash and uh Sandhill
rahma Murthy who's Ramsay Rosso slash
blood work
um
and so yeah man just one last time strap
on those [ __ ] tights and an arrow and
maybe don't fail this city
this isn't don't fail this city deep
Cuts yeah
um and finally
um and I found this interesting that
Sherlock Holmes is finally entirely in
the public domain
um copyright Zone works from 1927
including Arthur Conan Doyle's final
short Story collection the case book of
Sherlock Holmes has expired becoming
free for public use without permission
or cost
as more Works into the public domain
after an extended 95-year period other
books in doing the public domain include
uh Herbert ashbury's The Gangs of New
York Agatha Christie's the big four
William Faulkner's mosquitoes and Ernest
Hemingway's men without women films like
The Jazz Singer Wings which is the
winner of the first ever Academy Award
for that sitting picture and Metropolis
for its Lang's seminal work
um musical compositions like Irving
Berlin's Putting on the Ritz
um Duke Ellington and Bob Bob Milly's
black and tan fantasy and some other
stuff
um so yeah man if you want to make a
Sherlock Holmes movie go ahead you don't
got to pay nobody just like if you want
to make a Winnie the Pooh story go ahead
now there's some elements of Winnie the
Pooh you can't use I think ticker was an
invention or or Eeyore was intervention
something comes from the animated stuff
that is not public domain but that is
how they're making a Winnie the Pooh
Blood and Honey horror film right
because it's not public domain so
go for it y'all
um so that means nobody owns Sherlock
Holmes anymore correct belongs to the
universe
and Sherlock Holmes just went available
this year I mean it's it had been parts
of it had been available same year as
Mickey Mouse he's going uh
yeah Steamboat Willie Mickey is going to
about to enter public domain yeah I'm
sure Disney will have some version of
and I think Disney might have even been
behind the uh the copyright term
extension Act
um yeah which was in 1998. because
Corporation 1927 including his team but
really we're set to expire in 2022 and
the 98 copyright extension act extended
that expiration date to 2023.
um so yeah man it's uh it's a Brave New
World if you wanted to do Sherlock
Holmes Versus uh Dracula you 100 could
because both of those are in the public
you don't have to pay anybody jack [ __ ]
you could do [ __ ] Sherlock Holmes
versus Dracula versus Winnie the Pooh
[ __ ] yeah
foreign
Sherlock Holmes Watson dies teams up
with Jay and Silent Bob to solve a
mystery
you could do all of those things I don't
have to ask anybody for permission
um what else we got you can get Dino
Rollins to play Sherlock Holmes but he's
oh that'd be amazing Sherlock homie
and you could get
don't give away good ideas like that
go homes what
come solve this [ __ ] crime
they can team up with uh Freddie Prince
Jr you could call him Fred and you could
wear a white shirt and blue pants and
just don't ever
reference his dog
he's a detective but he's like I fell
out with my old friend
exactly I'm looking for a new gang
um somebody in chat
was saying something about some [ __ ]
news story that we didn't cover
and now I forget what it was so if
you're
we're about to wrap up the news is there
anything we didn't talk about kids
uh Lisa Lisa Marie Presley passed away
yeah all right we'll start there
um
before we jump into that anybody know
how Jeremy renner's doing
I think he's in
I think he's in stable condition
the last I heard you know like he was
given thumbs up from his hospital bed
after being pulverized by some kind of
Law and Machinery equipment
oh plows no cat or snowplow
um but yeah like it it seems to have
done some massive damage
um and he was he was critical for a
while but I think that would be stable
I've seen I I saw
police report like you know some
click bait headline where they were like
the police say what really happened with
Jeremy Renner and of course I was like
really
clicked on it and the story was that he
was
the sheriff was like he was trying to
help somebody shovel out their car he's
always trying to help people
look like a really nice story and gave
it the most clickbaity headline like a
dick I was like oh what is the real
story and the real story is like he's a
real nice guy
I have news that every other outlets
already broke but uh I saw it firsthand
last night
uh Steven Spielberg and John Williams
did a little
chat discussing their 50 years of
collaboration on his movies
and uh they asked John Williams if he
was really retiring from making movies
and he said uh I can never say no to
Steven Spielberg so Steven asks me to
come back to do another movie I will
whoa so John Williams maybe is not done
yet he said uh you know I can't imagine
my life without music and uh so
that's good news for everybody
it is oh yeah he worked he did the score
for famous right yeah that was supposed
to be his last score
the movie's wonderful
um I didn't love it as much as you did
you go to hell
get up keep going we are finished
um they said in chat there's a new alien
TV show do you know about this
um yes it is uh Noah Holly who had done
Fargo oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he's been
working on that for a while but I think
the news out of tcas which I think the
winter tcas are happening this week from
John langraff is that they are they are
prepping to film it prepping for
production for this year
um but no other real details beyond that
um and also a lot of people are saying
in chat I don't I mean it it doesn't
seem like a rumor uh Jeff Beck passed
away
I didn't come across that news but I
think it just happened while we were
doing the show no it was yesterday or
last night
yeah
is that right
um
check this out
Michael Ferdinand he did a mark Bernard
and he's got a pitch for what I saw it
sounds like a pretty decent movie movie
called public domain where a film
student goes to get an idea for a thesis
and finds a magical book that brings
public domain characters to life
foreign
okay
you're harsh
you didn't support that can't co-sign
that Jeff Beck passed away two days ago
people are saying it was the other day
it's the 10th yeah
um Lisa Marie Presley did pass away uh
yesterday I think
um and that was just
crazy [ __ ] sad yeah 55 years old I
think so young she's got that song
um lights out is that what it was
um someone turned the lights out down in
Memphis there's this line in that song
that was always kind of Haunting where
she talked about
um last time I was there she's talking
about Graceland this whole song
she goes last time I was there I noticed
a space left in the ground there in
Memphis and she was singing about her
grave because they tend to bury the
whole family there
um
so sad
to think that she's headed to that grave
this early like
she my mom was heartbroken she's like I
remember when they had the press
conference and she came home and like
you know
uh I guess for like a lot of older
people she's been
they they saw her whole life span she's
just always been around since I've been
around and stuff and um
you know I [ __ ] with Graceland fairly
recently like last year I took Grace my
mom to Graceland
and um fell down a bit of an Elvis hole
which we won't get into here of course
uh again
if you know Elvis made
um but like while I was at Graceland
there's a lot of uh Lisa Marie stuff and
and um
you know I never met her or anything
like that but she seemed like a sweet
sweet person the uh
it was very sad they had her you know
her she had her daughters Riley Keough
the actress
um but she also had a son and he passed
away and he was
like buried there on the other side of
of Elvis
um she's far too young to be going in
the ground man
it's a shame what was it Mass Cardiac
Arrest Cardiac Arrest is what I saw
reported
um but I don't know if they've yet done
the autopsy in the field anything beyond
that
um
somebody says Kevin's way too high
number one no such thing uh but number
two God no not at all I'll tell you if
I'm baking [ __ ]
um I was more I was more sad you know
about this whole thing I mean is she not
that much older than me and I survived a
hard thing so
it's a bummer man it's a real bummer
um yeah
um
she was just uh at the Golden Globes
like I they saw a clip where she was
talking Austin Butler who won for Elvis
yeah
um
who I'd be remiss if I didn't point out
was also in yoga hosers
years ago kids you found it when he was
young
um but uh yeah what oh somebody just
Kurt Frazier said Adam Rich also passed
away 54 a couple days ago that was
Nicholas from [ __ ] Eight is Enough
young Nicholas
he passed away he was young
I I I I I uh
whose grandma died at 46. Robert Mills
says her grandma died of 46 who Lisa
Marie
mother no she I thought she lived way
longer than that
um
yeah 54 Ben bamboo says 54 is not enough
you ain't kidding man I mean geez I love
that song lights out her that album was
good
um
all right yeah uh Laura D says can we
change the subject now yeah it's sad
yeah
uh
I live in Little Rock we are all
heartbroken two hours from Memphis
um
Boston saying this is Kevin why are you
thinner uh I had a
please don't make me [ __ ] bring up
the heart attack that somebody earlier
accused me of bringing up far too much
but uh in February on the 25th when you
can see me and Ralph doing uh Babylon
heart attack adversary show at Flappers
tickets at cspod.com
um five years ago I had heart attack and
uh after that I went vegan and then I
started exercising more and stuff like
that and you know I'm trying to stay
alive that's it eventually
uh okay
we're done with the News That's all the
news nobody else has news done with the
news done with the news man
um Gladys Presley died in 58 she was
born in 1912.
oh said Robert Mills wow you all right I
think there's a guy who knows more about
Elvis than me
maxplay says wait Kevin had a heart
attack
[Music]
two things I know about me or two things
you'll never not know about me one I
made clerks the other is that heart
attack
I talk about them in excessively
um okay
um dude says the dude just dude how'd
you get that name says no Ezra talk is
there any Ezra talk to be had what
happened uh he just signed a plea deal
and I think Vermont courts to get out of
some of those I'm sorry they have signed
a plea deal in Vermont courts to uh to
get out of the charges of house arrest
illegal house arrest or imprisonment or
whatever that was basically it's a year
of rehab and uh and and no alcohol
or whatever it is
um feels a little slap in the wrist dish
but also you know the the days of movie
studios still having some influence over
what happens to their movie stars before
movies come out or not over
um
foreign
the Rob Brown Channel said made clerks
had heart attack big friends with Victor
Garber preachers
still haven't been able to [ __ ] close
the loop on that one uh Jason mckibble
and McKibben says what's up with
Constantine too is there news of
Constantine too
not that I've heard Beyond I knew they
wanted to make one and I think that they
had talked to Francis Lawrence and Keanu
Reeves about doing it but that was like
six months ago and so no no updates
Henry Pena in chat is writing in all
caps and he writes I am writing in all
caps witness me
it's funnier than me Ah that's not
difficult it's being called constant
tune like with the two instead of an eye
guns and Twine
it was announced Kyler J says yeah okay
here's the here's the Ezra Miller stuff
okay after being charged for stealing
liquor from a Vermont neighbor in May
Ezra Miller's plea deal for reduced
sentence of trespassing was accepted
Friday by a superior court judge in the
Green Mountain State
in addition to paying 500 Miller will
also need to serve one year on
administrative probation
[Music]
as part of the plea agreement here the
state will dismiss without prejudice
counts one and two of the burglary and
petite larceny
um
yeah
The Flash star was originally charged
with three counts of burglary but Petit
petite larceny sounds adorable and
trespassing in a May first incident that
involved Miller breaking into Stanford
Vermont neighbor Isaac winiker's Pantry
in which he lifted a bottle of gin
vodkan rum Virginia State Police didn't
locate Miller to issue recitation until
August 7th
sorry but Peter crickson in in the
comments section wrote why didn't he run
why didn't they run
uh yeah it's just you know I know
[ __ ] the people that play the
characters aren't expected to be the
characters in real life I you know I'm
I'm look I [ __ ] play Silent Bob and
you can't shut my [ __ ] dumb ass up
that being said it just feels weird that
the guy who plays that they who play The
Flash is
so in trouble with the law
or maybe not anymore is this it are they
good I don't think so I think there were
a bunch of other issues that had
surrounded said person
um this being maybe the most minor of
them
broken and stole some some booze as
opposed to you know keeping children
hostage with loaded guns around and
uh oh man
are there still going to be a movie
starring this person
yeah you can't stop it
no he's trying
they're trying their best
to stop it
[Music]
that movie is happening there come
Heller Highway
um yeah everyone's talking about like
the movie's supposed to be great I I
hear the movies
really wonderful
um all right
why are we Boston saying this is Kevin
Mark talk about AI in Hollywood why is
that a topic this week
I hope it's a topic this week as much as
you know there's
the the there's a big movement I suppose
against AI in the art world because if
you go on to apps or websites like
mid-journey you can input a bunch of
Search terms that it will create for you
um a piece of artwork
um using
millions of images that have been
scanned in from some people who you know
potentially did not give permission for
those images to be scanned into and so
there are artists who believe that that
will
sort of Empower people to skip hiring
actual artists to do things like concept
illustration and design work and you
know pre-visualization of stuff if they
can just type in the search terms and
get what they think they want
um it is not a good thing
um it only opens the door to bad things
and there are now I think apps in one of
those called like chat GPT that is uh
for writers where they can say give me a
eight page term paper on the you know
the economic forces that created blah
blah blah and then you could reliably
count on it to churn out words that make
sense
whether or not that will ever get so far
as to hey I would like you to write me a
Blockbuster movie computer here's what I
want it to be about here's what I want
the conflicts to be here's where I want
the plot points to turn go for it and
then have something churn out for you
100 Pages that's a screenplay that you
can get then go shoot
um
I mean it's you know I've done enough
talking writing
making terrible movies that I'm sure at
this point that you could ask you know
an AI like just [ __ ]
give me another [ __ ] Kevin Smith
thing and they could pretty much deliver
it's a bread State that'd be tough to
replicate fantastic that was weird too
yeah I mean I think that Parks too one
of a kind
that's that's the thing is that you can
100 input a bunch of Storytelling Dogma
pardon the pun
um about structure and about plot and
about character and it it could
theoretically give you something that
looks like a movie but will not have any
inspiration won't know where to make
mistakes or to do things that have never
been done before you won't get
originality you will just get a carbon
copy of something else
um which is the only thing that gives me
some semblance of uh
solace
and chat goes write me a Kevin Smith
movie dot dot not yoga hosers
Um well hey man I always felt like you
know
much like uh
the chef in Ratatouille the dead ghost
guy anyone can cook and uh anybody could
ride on a good day
everybody got at least one interesting
story in them and stuff well we found
out that the robots can do it too
it's just weird though that like
you know it used to be
you could copy [ __ ] from an encyclopedia
for a report then I would imagine you
could copy and paste
from Wikipedia or whatever for a report
in school now you could literally not
even do the report and just be like
computer confirm
it writes the report for you that's nuts
does it say how long it is is it
instantaneous I don't know what the
processing time is like
um
not entirely sure of that you know and
I'm sure that you'd have to continue to
poke it in product to revise it and get
it close to something
usable but
I don't know man
I don't know and and I do think the uh
the gusto
Maxim was anyone can cook
which was not the meaning it was a good
cook can come from anywhere as antonigo
would then later correct us too and so
like yeah like you don't you don't need
higher education you don't need parents
in the biz you don't need whatever to be
a writer good writers can come from
anywhere
but
not everyone can write
Henry Pena says Kev anybody can sing
happy birthday but when Celine Dion does
it dot dot you know
I guess so does she sing her I mean look
she's I I get that she's an amazing
singer but does she do an incredible
happy birthday
um his point is just like
you know and the AI can write a script
but it doesn't it ain't gonna be like
you know [ __ ] an errant circus group
right yeah ai ai will never get you Pulp
Fiction because none of that is
according to any conventionally
perceived screen reading formulas or
maxims or even
this is how we do this you couldn't put
100 screenplays into it Ai and expect to
get Pulp Fiction out the other side I'm
sorry I can't let you say that without
doing this this is how we do this
is how we do this it's Friday night oh
my God it's literally Friday night I
feel all right that's right I got [ __ ]
to do after this man I forgot I got a
screening it's my castle Cinemas hey hey
what hey are you on the East Coast uh
you watching the show you hey 10 o'clock
we're showing Friday the 13th man the
intro it talk some [ __ ] before the movie
drop some science that's what I love
about moving I own a movie there I just
walk downstairs and force the audience
to listen to my thoughts
eat for this shut up and listen to my
thoughts start the movie shut up
don't don't [ __ ] tell me to shush
Silent Bob
that's pretty good
um all right we're done with the news
done with the news I mean that it's time
for bathman to hit it so we can quit it
bamf all right got a bunch of good
questions pick three
nice uh the first one
skank hunt 42. if you could make
special a special Star Wars Parody
episode of any sitcom Pastor present
what show would you choose to do and who
would play the different parts
first off uh my grandma's maiden name
was skag hunt so this is very touching
um second off what was the question
again
[Laughter]
uh pick your sitcom
and and do a Star Wars Parody episode so
like Star Wars people in it Like That
70s Show did a Star Wars parody where
like uh Donna played Leia and Eric
Foreman played
uh Luke Skywalker like pick a six some
sort of dream sequence or something yeah
they did it in a dream sequence they're
like Family Guy did it where they like
put all of their characters as Star Wars
characters and did like a spoof
interesting Okay so
what show do I want them to do a Star
Wars episode in
Sharon Noble
laughs
you can see that right [ __ ] like
through the ruskin's dressing up like
Darth Vader and they're like duh you
will all die
one that makes the most sense would be
like Big Bang Theory right
like that's a no-brainer I can't imagine
it wasn't every episode some sort of
Star Wars
um
it's no imagining Stellan skarsgard's
crazy Russian dude
meltdown a military meltdown the name
the factory
I don't know you got one Mark I got one
I got one I think I would like to
imagine
um as
as Han Solo you would have uh Frasier
Crane as Luke Skywalker you'd have his
brothers Niles
as Obi-Wan Kenobi you'd have the dad
Martin
as Princess Leia you would get Roz Doyle
and uh and they're just the Millennium
Falcon is their living room
and Eddie the dog is Chewbacca daddy the
dog is Chewbacca Frazier as Star Wars
Star Wars is Frasier I see the game
you're playing and the moments like this
I realized like
I don't have that Mad Magazine Gene
I'm finding it hard to get my head
around this formula
um
[Music]
hmm
hmm
I was about cheers
like and he said come between 1985.
um
Taxi
no all right
The Facts of Life
so Mrs Garrett is Ben Kenobi
cutie is Luke Skywalker I know everyone
expects me to say Lando no she's Luke
Skywalker
because she's always so like bright-eyed
like Luke
uh [ __ ] Joe is definitely Han Solo
where is Princess Leia oh my God I did
it see look at that
man a minute man
I played your [ __ ] game skank Hunter
and I won
half man you got an answer for this [ __ ]
or can we move on I I think let's move
on I don't have anything give me more
contributing to this this one Star Wars
question that he wants to pass on I was
like I'm gonna have a great answer for
this and then no I'm not gonna beat
Mark's answer so for those who came in
late
um hey go download amp the app because
next week I start
Uh Kevin Smith's movie music in the
morning on the amp app uh oh I lost
another light God damn it I need these
jobs because I can't pay my electric
bill
uh download it and follow Kevin Smith
man three days a week Monday Wednesdays
Fridays and it's from 9am
to 11 A.M
uh
PST
there you go all right into the next
question uh the OG zombie
um says Martin Luther King Day is on
Monday
if you were going to give Dr King super
powers what superpower would you give
him and why
[Music]
well you know wasn't the idea that like
Charles Xavier was always kind of meant
to be the Martin Luther King of
comics of sorts so I don't know give him
Charles Xavier's Powers man give him
cerebral cerebro because he's black
cerebral
cerebral
yeah I mean it was all that was the
early sort of analogy was that yeah
Charles Xavier is Martin Luther King and
Magneto was Malcolm X that they both
wanted the same thing
but would go to far different lengths to
achieve them
um
so yeah my mental powers to change parts
and Minds seems like it would be high on
the uh on the Malcolm I'm sorry on the
Martin Luther King powered list
um
I don't know man I feel like making a Mr
Fantastic would also be [ __ ] awesome
he's brilliant yeah super brilliant and
crazy stretchy
just for fun just for [ __ ] shits and
giggles
uh yeah like his words like his words
could influence and change Minds right
that would be like the on the nose but
it's like an actual superpower
he's just Banshee like every time he
screams it
[Music]
he's flying where's it going
I've gone to the top of the mountain I
may not stay here with you because I can
also fly
I just realized wasn't the guy who
played banshee
in the was it banshee
yeah from first class is also the dude
who was in
get out play the brother the shitty
brother
let's put that [ __ ] together Mr lacrosse
he's always playing the shitty brother
in some way isn't he
plays a lot of a lot of villains except
for that Banshee thing
the actor that guy
oh my God
uh Stanley asked has JC been to Kevin's
theater not yet
a couple weeks probably coming two or
three minutes
Eastbound and Down 18 Wheels and
building what are you gonna do with this
it can't be done
you always go 18 Wheels and rolling
because that's in the lyrics
Eastbound and Down loaded up and
trucking I think we can change it up
throughout
like I think it's like first first
second first
but in the movie too like they probably
came in with loaded up and trucking
after they got all the cores right like
that's the first time they do that song
like like look verse one is loaded up
and Trucking and then verse two is
eighteen wheels and Roland
and I'm sure there's a third verse I
would [ __ ] with some Smokey and the
Bandit film festival at least one and
two maybe not three but [ __ ] one you
need to go to the point where it's just
Jerry Reed yes you can yeah best
burtless movie ever made
[Laughter]
um all right what else we got
Banff uh last one
um
this is from Tom Herbert Doyle in
Australia
oh good day wants to know if you could
jump forward in time once and then live
the rest of your life there how many
years forward would you go
I could jump forward and live there for
the rest of my life in that one year
well you'd like yeah so like you could
go 2 000 years in the future
and hope that uh
they can put your head in a jar like
Futurama and you can live forever like
how far in the future do you go if you
have a chance to go into the future
oh okay I'm not a very adventurous or
courageous man or even person remove my
gender as a human being I'm not very
courageous I'm fear-based and somebody
told me that recently who was it Jason's
wife Jordan she goes you're pretty
fear-based
and I was first I I wanted to get mad at
her but then I was afraid
thank you
um I
um I don't know why I started telling
that story oh fear-based means I would
not go
thousand years into the future for fear
of it being like a dystopian [ __ ]
nightmare
or not even a dystopian nightmare what
if it's just like you know in this in
the future or anyone with a beard is
executed or something like that we're
wearing a backwards baseball cap you
know that's that's you might as well
[ __ ] scream Hitler in a crowded movie
theater or some said [ __ ] worse they
have no baseball caps
well no then then I Ruled then I'm their
king and leader because I've got it
as far as they know that's how you're
supposed to wear it I don't know that I
would jump that far can I go back in
time
can I go back in time
I let's yeah that it's not part of the
question but why not
oh it's not all right let's stick to the
rules so I'm only going forward only
going forward
you're only going into the unknown
you can't always look to the Past you
gotta look forward
um here we go I'm looking forward
wait do when I get there am I that old
or am I as old your same age so you're
the same age so you could go 100 years
in the future and live out the rest of
your life at that point
from this age forward correct yes
can I go to a place where I coexist with
myself
I think what do I have to do far enough
away that I'm dead
I mean this becomes very Grim if it's
like I gotta figure then I know when I
die in order to make this jump and I
can't be in the same place for a risk of
one of us stopping existing they gotta
essentially give me the like well you
you know I'm not saying anything but
don't go before June 12th 2014 or
whatever 2014 I'd be dead already
2084 or whatever the [ __ ] I'm not gonna
live that long either I'm not good at
this 20 30.
um maybe the time Cup rules don't have
to apply
which is another movie foreign
but you do a fat man
with fat man show where it's your Future
Self
co-hosting a show with your past self
telling your future self about the
movies that they can watch now that
they've already come out I'm getting the
inside Dope From Me
yeah
Kevin's just gonna time travel like
three four years in the future to see
Secret Wars and then come back and tell
them how good it was what a good there
it is there's my [ __ ] answer yeah
like May 2026 oh my God and they're like
don't you want to like travel to see
your daughter get married have a kid I'm
like you know
if that's happening adjacent to Secret
Wars then I would love to pop in and see
that right I'll be there save me a seat
um yeah I yeah yeah
I think as far as I feel safe going
can I come back is that or am I trapped
there forever
you're trapped there that's the rest of
it
so like if you go beyond like like you
went 20 years in the future you could
like
see Harley when she was like in her 40s
and be like hey look at this and like
live out
what a weird fantasy movie that is it's
like I want to travel back in time and
meet my daughter in her 40s
like why
yeah like I don't know I saw her when
she was a baby and she was pretty happy
I always wondered if she'd grow up and
be shitty and depressed
take me to my daughter at age 40.
Kevin it's your kid
why is she an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
foreign
age 23 blames me for everything anyway
right now might as well jump to age 40.
um
I I don't know yeah
I don't know I
think what do I know what happened in
the missing time that I jumped to no
you're just like hey it's the year 2000
80
and like now you get to catch up like
would you travel to like Star Trek times
in hopes
that Society what the [ __ ] is Star Trek
times it's fiction bro
it's like referring a Game of Thrones
it's medieval it's like
it's hard track times
um don't be silly but you could go back
to Star Wars times a long time ago yeah
in a galaxy far far away
because that's history
yes that's history that happened
uh Darth Smirnoff says Kevin has way too
many questions for this simple question
I guess I'm reading way too much so many
improvises
people like just say five and let's move
on I don't know I'm taking this real
seriously
all right so I'm 52. it's just what I'm
having a problem with is
like what what happened like did I make
clerks for what happened between when I
jumped and landed like will I if I look
in history books film history or the
internet will it say like he Kevin Smith
disappeared the day that I Disappeared
to jump to the future or will I read
about all these wonderful adventures
that I had that I don't remember because
I bypassed them because I jumped to the
[ __ ] future because quite like
another famous myth
I quote I Don't Want to Miss a Thing
I I think according to to whatever his
name's rules are yes you disappear
you vanish from your life and then you
reappear in the time that you you've
designated
and so people will have buried you or
whatever like they'll have buried a
backward baseball cap and a couple of
buttons on a Blazer
and have said the ceremonies and I've
done the things and made peace with it
and then you show back up
yeah it's like a it's like the the snap
or the blip but then you you you get to
choose when you blip back
uh Nick Johnson says jump 30 years and
you can see all the Marvel and DC films
that's a good point at once just [ __ ]
spend a weekend
in your movie theater you could sell
tickets to them
and and not have to pay the the 90 back
to the studio you'd be like I'm gonna
get Iron Man 12 for 300 bucks and talk
about it because I've never seen it and
everybody else has
or even better is like they're probably
all in the public domain if I jump far
enough maybe that's what I do
or the public domain what I do here is a
multi-part plan
the brainstorm some really good [ __ ]
ideas for characters that we could never
touch in this lifetime me and Mark then
I jumped to the time when that shit's in
the public domain
and [ __ ]
does that make us rich probably not
it
or or you you jump into the future like
30 years and then you still have the
movie theater and then the event is
Kevin's Resurrection Day come watch all
the movies he's missed with him you can
sell those tickets like nobody's [ __ ]
business oh you're not kidding we would
sell out in a day easy
so when I leave
is it like a big [ __ ] Center like is
the high school band there and
everyone's seeing me off because we know
I'm gonna return and [ __ ] like I I
knowing me I'm making a big thing of it
so I'm on stage in front of a full
theater going like people of Atlantic
Islands I Journey now into the future
like Phineas fog like you're about to
come around the world in any
but so so that I can predict when I'm
going to come back and [ __ ] like so I
could say oh it's gonna be this date
yeah
it's a time capsule and people are like
is he really jumping to the future or is
he just
I don't know going away did he just blow
himself up yeah is he cryogenically
freezing himself yeah I guess that could
roll with that sort of thing it's the
prestige just like he just [ __ ]
vanished
it's the prestige you [ __ ] killed his
twin brother
that's how important this [ __ ] was
to him
there's a field full of hats and bunnies
out there he's been doing some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] had some buddies
um all right
no closer to an answer no
uh let me see
what am I really most looking forward to
movie wise I mean that [ __ ] like
picked 30 years and see all the movies
is pretty smart like I guess I could do
that
and then when I'm done watching them I
can see if like Harley's still around
and
I mean I might still be around in 30
years how old am I 52. make it to 82. so
it could be I disappear and I show back
up and there's me
and I get to find out what I did while I
was gone no we established I can't do
this let's just say 30 years and move on
okay
uh I'm going to Star Trek times
yeah
right like you jump ahead A Thousand
Years
with the hope that it's better and it's
not like Days of Future Past you're like
next gen not Days of Future Past yeah
like I'm hoping for like you know 2400.
like we'll have [ __ ] dealt with all
this [ __ ] we'll have figured out the
the environment will have figured out
the economy well if you know gotten rid
of morons or at least kept them Orange
from being in charge of too many things
um space travel is real you can probably
live for like two or three hundred years
because we fixed that [ __ ]
like the Utopia the promised Utopia of
Tomorrow is what I'm banking on
and then flying cars finally playing
cars [ __ ] [ __ ] robots like all of
it like old job robots exist now they're
not great like the good ones
oh my God
that's that's your negative person
you're like yeah that exists but they're
not great I mean they're fine
you gotta learn to live with like good
enough that's my middle name Kevin good
enough Smith no I want I want the I want
the Cherry 2000 to [ __ ] [ __ ]
robots I don't want you know
so
Harry two thousand wow Freddie Prince Jr
brought that movie up to me yesterday
and he's like
Kevin hasn't seen that you gotta go and
watch Cherry 2000 with Kevin and and
Melanie Griffith plays this like she's
in it and like this guys
what 48 hours two people have brought it
up and yeah it's [ __ ] so weird and I
had never heard of it now I have to go
watch it
yeah see
is that in the public domain should we
remake that yet
I think you got to file some serial
numbers
entering the public domain this year
Sherlock Holmes uh Steamboat Willie
Mickey Mouse and interestingly enough
Cherry 2000. going to see young Melanie
Griffith Melody Griffith is like I'm not
dead yet how did this happen
um boy uh somebody in chat said that my
answer felt like it took 30 years uh
Mark's answer was very quick and to the
point well I I had time to think about
it
um all right there bamf man answer we
the question three
that was three right yeah that's three
we're done yeah we're down start smoking
more all right [ __ ] that's it then
there it is the whole show ends on
[ __ ] robots there you go
this never was
Jose Munster said we should have gone to
the Future to hear Kevin's answer
Jason McKibben said that was funny Mark
I liked your thing
sometimes
it all comes out of the wash man mccag
says I'm not too high in quotes from
some guy that's too high I'm not too I
don't know I just really wanted to think
about my answer I think it it deserved
consideration
it was a good question that required
some mental thought these are my
favorites man
kids we're at an end
my night's not even over oh [ __ ] my
computer's about to die it has a six
percent oh then we gotta go
you do got to go uh in a couple hours
I'm gonna be downstairs introducing
Friday the 13th happy Friday the 13th by
the way everybody we are showing Friday
the 13th here at smog Castle Cinemas uh
because it was shot and not only is it
Friday the 13th but they shot it here in
New Jersey
oh yeah local pride and then tomorrow is
uh Iron Man Mary Marvel marching movie
sorry Society we're giving out stickers
[ __ ] come join the club gonna be a
good time what do you got to sell there
Mark
um I got nothing but uh if you want to
buy a door in the distance copies are
still on sale
um next Tuesday the LA the final issue
of census drops in your comixology
Originals
um it'll be collected by Dark Horse
sometime in the spring but if you want
to just keep up with it monthly the
final the final of five
issues drops next Tuesday so pick it up
census comixology Originals uh JC's got
a bars coming villain in Cantina in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard go
there someday we'll be back
yeah uh and uh amp Kids Go download the
amp app Amazon's live music radio amp I
got my own show Kevin Smith's movie
music in the morning starting next week
I believe Monday Wednesdays and Fridays
Man download that amp thing it's only
for uh Apple users I think Android users
can listen to it through
well [ __ ] themselves
[Laughter]
kids
you got a blast the [ __ ] robot could
literally be Android user
oh no
[ __ ] sponsored this sucks 5000. uh
kids
[ __ ] uh there ain't no show without
the the guy over there give it up for
the great Mark Bernardin kids oh thank
you very much good sir there it is man
there is your HEAP and help a fat man
beyond for this week uh that's fat man
beyond for fat man beyond I'm good I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernard tune in
next time
there's Batman tune in next time same
that time same fat channels podcast.com
or youtube.com Kevin Smith
Jeff's kiss uh to 2023 kids um
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old up Kevin
Smith
[Music]